les vidéos banana toif magali minutes
vous ne vous êtes jamais demandé d'où
ils viennent ils vivent sur cette
planète depuis bien plus longtemps que
nous ils sont tous différents et ils ont
tous le même métier servir deux maîtres
le plus moche mais chose soir
[Musique]
trouver un maître et et python simple le
garder c'est là que les choses se
gâtaient
[Musique]
et non ce n'était pas facile pour eux
pourtant ils n'ont jamais abandonné
[Musique]
à alors papa kane à tous les pèlerins
canapa paillasse m messieurs
est ce que l'un de vous n'a jamais rêvé
de travailler pour le plus grand super
méchant de tous les temps
voici les nouvelles recrues un scanner
canon sur toutes les bouches je ne
comprendrai rien
vous savez qui c'est la côte à la carte
ça c'est la reine elizabeth rire et je
veux vraiment vraiment vraiment sans
couronne rouge est venu pour la couronne
de la reine
ces phares il vous faudra passer sur le
corps du gardien de la couronne a relevé
[Musique]
nkoulou
les quêtes le même état
ben oui y'a pas de scarlett qui tienne
surtout ne prenez pas mal mais je vous
déteste et maintenant torture les gars
arrêtez c'est vraiment pas professionnel
suit bellerive